Have you ever been in an
argument about nuclear power?
We have and we found it
frustrating and confusing,
so let's try and get to
grips with this topic.
Yeah.
It all started in the 1940s after the
shock and horror of the war and they use
of the atomic bomb.
Nuclear energy promised to be a peaceful
spinoff of the new technology helping
the world get back on its feet.
Everyone's imagination was running
wild wood and electricity become free.
Could nuclear power help
settle the Antarctic?
Would there be nuclear powered
cars, planes, or houses?
It seemed that this was just
a few years of hard work away.
One thing was setting
the future was a tonic.
Just a few years later, there was a sort
of atomic age hangover. As it turned out,
nuclear power was a very complicated
and very expensive turning physics into
engineering. Was it easy on paper,
but hard in real life? Also,
private companies thought that nuclear
power was much too risky as an investment.
Most of them would much rather
stick with gas, coal, and oil.
But there were many people who didn't
just want to abandon the promise of the
atomic age and exciting new technology,
the prospect of enormously
cheap electricity,
the prospect of being independent oil
and gas in boards and in some cases a
secret desire to possess
the atomic weapons provided
a strong motivation to keep
going.
Nuclear powers at finest hour finally
came in the early 1970s when war in the
Middle East cause to oil prices
to skyrocket worldwide. Now,
commercial interest and investment
picked up at eight dazzling pace.
More than half of all the nuclear reactors
in the world were built between 1970
and 1985 but which type of reactor to
build given how many different types there
were to choose from. And he surprising
underdog candidate won the day.
The light water reactor.
It wasn't very innovative and it
wasn't too popular with scientists,
but it had some decisive advantages.
It was there,
it works and it wasn't terribly expensive.
So what doesn't like water?
He had to do well.
The basic principle is shockingly simple.
It heats up water using an
artificial chain reaction.
Nuclear Fission release is several million
times more energy than any chemical
reaction could.
Really heavy elements on the brink of
stability like uranium two three five get
bombarded with neutrons.
The neutrons is absorbed,
but the result is
unstable most of the time.
It immediately splits into
fast moving laser elements,
some additional free neutrons and
energy in the form of radiation.
The radiation heat to the
surrounding water, well,
the neutrons repeat the process with
other items releasing more neutrons and
radiation in a closely
controlled chain reaction.
Very different from the first destructive
runaway reaction in an atomic bomb in
our light water reactor, a moderator is
needed to control the neutrons energy.
Simple ordinary water does the job,
which is very practical since water's
used to drive the turbines anyway,
the light water reactor became prevalent
because it's simple and cheap. However,
it's neither the safest, most efficient
nor technically elegant nuclear reactor.
The renewed nuclear hype
lasted barely a decade though.
In 1979 the three mile island nuclear
plant in Pennsylvania barely escaped a
catastrophe when it's core melted.
In 1986 the Chernobyl catastrophe
directly threatened central Europe with a
radioactive cloud.
And in 2011 the drawn out
Fukushima disaster sparks
new discussions and concerns
while in the 1980s 218 new nuclear power
reactors when live their number and
nuclear as global share of electricity
production has stagnated since the end of
the eighties so what's the
situation today? Today,
nuclear energy meets around 10% of the
world's energy demand that are about 439
nuclear reactors in 31 countries.
About 70 new reactors aren't under
construction in 2015 most of the men
countries, which are
growing quickly, all in all,
116 new reactors are planned worldwide.
Most new via reactors were built
more than 25 years ago with Prezi.
Old Technology, more than 80% are
various types of light water reactor.
Today.
Many countries are faced with a choice,
the expensive replacement of the aging
renters possibly with more efficient but
less tested models or a move away from
nuclear power towards newer or older
technology with different cost
and environmental impacts.
So should we use nuclear energy?
The pro and contra arguments
will be presented here next week.
Subscribe and then you won't miss it.
Our channel has a new sponsor,
audible.com if you use the URL [inaudible]
dot com slash nutshell you can get a
free audio book and support our channel.
Producing our videos takes a lot of time
and we fill a lot of it by listening to
audio books for already entertaining
book we recommend into thin air by Jon
Krakauer. He's a great writer and the
story is really absorbing and true.
Go to audible.com/nutshell
to get the book for free.
Thanks a lot to audible for supporting
our channel and to you for watching.